So when we analyzed Newton's
Second Law-- applied
to this compound system--
we had two equations
for Object 1 and Object 2.
And what we found is that
we had three unknowns--
the tension in the string and
the accelerations of the two
objects.
Now, how do we
solve this system?
Well, we're missing
one condition, which
is a constraint condition.
Which is, as Object 2
moves and Object 1 moves,
they have to move in some
relationship together.
And now what we'd
like to do is show
an analytic approach for finding
that constraint condition.
And the way we think
about it is that,
we'll call l equal to
the length of the string,
and this quantity is a constant.
And what we'd like
to do is introduce
coordinate functions for
our Object 1 and our Object
2 and express l in terms of
those coordinate functions.
And then, take two derivatives
of l, set that equal to 0
because it's a
constant, and that
will give us a relationship
between the accelerations
of Objects 1 and 2.
Now, this is a
little bit tricky.
And so, what we want to
do is, very carefully,
show how we introduce
coordinate functions.
Recall that we had j hat 1
down and j hat 2 downwards.
What that implies is that
we're choosing some origin
and we're-- let's choose
an origin up here--
and for a coordinate
function for Object 1,
it has to be consistent with our
choice of what we mean by j hat
1.
So, in this sense, y1
is a positive quantity
when we're going downward.
Now, what about
coordinate functions
for the other objects
in the system?
Well, let's look at
a few things first.
This is a fixed
distance-- we'll call
it s1-- between the ceiling
and the center of the pulley.
And let's make each of
the pulleys a radius, r.
And let's call this
a function y b.
And let's make this y2 of t.
So now we have coordinate
functions for 2
and coordinate functions for 1.
And again, recall that
this distance here-- s2--
is a fixed distance.
And when we define these
coordinate functions
in this fashion, we know that
the second derivative-- d
squared y1 dt squared--
this is precisely what we
mean by the acceleration
of Object 1.
And in the similar
fashion, d squared
y2 dt squared is what we mean
by the acceleration of Object 2.
So we've introduced
a coordinate system,
we've made it very clear what we
mean by the accelerations of a1
and a2, and now let's look
at our constraint condition
that the length of the
string is constant.
So what we're going
to do is try to see
if we can express the length
of this string in terms of all
the coordinate
functions and some
of these ancillary quantities.
So what we have here is that
the length of the string
is y b going down here.
So the length of the
string has a factor y b.
It wraps around Pulley
b-- so that's pi R--
and it goes up to
this length here.
Now, this length
is y b minus s1.
So that's y b minus s1.
We wrap around the pulley
again-- that's pi R.
And now, we have this length
here, which is y1 minus s1.
s1?
Yeah.
And let's just make sure we
have all of our quantities here.
Now, we also have another
constraint condition,
that this length of
the string-- we're
going to call this l1-- we
have a second string here, l2.
And l2 is given by y2-- this
length is y2 minus y b--
and that was what we
called this constant, s2.
So we now have two string
lengths-- l2 equals y2 minus y
b-- and both of these
string lengths are constant.
And we have the following facts.
Let's start with this one first,
that the second derivative
of l2 dt squared-- because
the length of the string
is a constant, that's 0.
And that tells us, two
derivatives of this
is a2 and two derivatives
of that is a b.
And this is something that we
saw before, that block b and 2
are moving together.
So when we treated the system
as just b and 2 together,
we see that the
acceleration of 2
and the acceleration of
Pulley b are the same.
So we could have just
said that before we began.
Now, let's put these equations
aside for the moment.
And now let's consider taking
two derivatives of String 1.
Recall, String 1 is
this object here.
We'll call this String
1 and this String 2.
Now, again, if we take
two derivatives-- let's
look at our
expression first-- we
see that we have
two factors of y b
and we have a bunch of
constants whose derivative is 0.
So we don't have to worry about
the wrap around distances--
the pi R's-- we don't have to
worry about the constants-- s1.
All we have to think
about is which quantities
are changing in time.
So we have 2 a b when
we take two derivatives
and we have one factor
of a1-- and that's 0.
And now, because the
block and 2 and Pulley b
are accelerating together,
we have our condition,
which is 2 a2 plus a1 is 0-- or
that a1 is equal to minus 2 a2.
And that is the extra
constraint condition
that will enable us to solve
the system of equations.